my name is Kelly and I cheated on my
partner about eight years ago I was
about 23 24 and it had been with this
person for about three years at the time
we hadn't been intimate in about five to
six months and a friend of mine invited
me to pride in Atlanta
there was a all-girl party and this girl
was there and she was hitting on me I
let her know that night I have a
girlfriend and she was like that's fine
like we could be cool so we party for
two nights straight and on the second
night something came over me and I was
just like you know let's take a shower
together we get back to the hotel room
like just a shower like nothing more we
got back to the hotel room hopped in the
shower and actually nothing happened
while we were we were in the shower like
it was straight up like me washing her
down her doing the same and like call it
a night so it was late and I was like
you know what we have a big-ass
king-size bed you know stay the night I
was laying in the bed she was in like
the shades and we was talking and like
the Sun was coming up and everything was
cool and she was like you know I'm so
far from you can I like come over there
so I was like all right you know kind of
like knowing I should say no but also
like I said yes and I was just like oh
god what am I getting myself into but
also I want to do it of course I thought
about my partner but it's the
gratification takes over so I can't even
remember if it was good it was like
mediocre so like you know after you
cheat you're like oh my god this wasn't
even worth it I felt like
[ __ ] you know we had been together for
like almost three and a half years then
a part of me was just like I'm human and
you know this was a part of my desire
and I I went for it I haven't done it
since then it's really not in my nature
but I kind of been just like in six
months since then like nothing really
sticks and so I guess that leaves me to
the point of maybe I'm not the
relationship person know that I know of
my partner never found out and we don't
communicate today so I think the reason
why people cheat is it's a part of human
nature you know where sexual beings
monogamy has kind of been forced upon us
in society you know we feel like we have
to conform to just being with one person
to be honest like I should have just
left the relationship if I wasn't happy
or communicated that to my partner like
in the moment maybe a phone call like
hey you know there's this girl and I'm
really interested in her like what's
going on with us I mean it wouldn't have
been ideal but it would have been honest
and also you know I was about 23 24 at
the time I would have handled it much
differently now
[Music]